non monsieur pas là introduisez votre
billet derrière vous sur le côté du
portillon
[Musique]
la disparition des vieux autobus est un
peu de la disparition de tout ce vieux
Paris que nous aimons ah oui moi je la
regrette et puis j'ai beaucoup d'amis de
café qui mange comme moi
on se sent moins moins compressé
[Musique]
quand même avec le personnel de la RATP
ils sont moins brusques dans les on a
l'impression qu'on est qu'on est
confiant contact avec la rue et les
jeunes aussi en vrai
toujours l'été en ce moment parce qu'il
fait froid
on est beaucoup mieux que enfermé dans
toutes les nouveaux autobus pour la
plateforme découverte c'est très
agréable enfin moi je préfère les
anciens dans la mesure où c'est le pari
ancien qui qui ressort mais je conçois
très bien qu'on comprenne les nouveaux
autobus maintenant que ce soit plus
rationnel et
[Musique]
ça me permettait à notamment fumeur de
fumée tranquillement la petite cigarette
sur la plateforme et éventuellement pour
une personne en retard menteur marche
moi je suis pour les modernes alors pour
la facilité de conduite et le confort
des voyageurs bien sûr
sans trop de défaillance il poursuivait
son bonhomme de chemin sous la
plateforme parfois une gerbe d'étincelle
lorsque dans un virage le vieux bus
volait une caresse au pavé de Paris
l'automatisation hélas écarte le
pittoresque les nouveaux autobus ils
sont plus confortables il s'agisse du
modèle standard
2200 en service depuis 1965 de l'autobus
à etar je présenté les touristes et qui
connaît un grand succès auprès des
parisiens ou encore du minibus il
circule plus facilement 100
000 de plus en service prochainement
voici un exemple de la mise en harmonie
des transports en commun avec les
exigences du confort moderne
le réseau express régional et la belle
gare de Joinville
[Musique]
pour le RER l'aménagement des gares est
conçue pour les plus importantes sous
forme d'un complexe associant une gare
de métro une gare routière de
rabattement des lignes d'autobus et un
parc de stationnement journalier
aujourd'hui on oublie facilement que les
chantiers du RER ont connu d'énormes
difficultés les mauvais pas furent
finalement franchis puisque nous voici
déjà arrivé à Boissy-Saint-Léger
tout à côté de la gare les ateliers
d'entretien du matériel roulant ou le
train est attendu
[Musique]
la RATP elle ne pas digne pas avec
l'entretien de son matériel les rames
passent sous la machine à laver tous les
trois jours
[Musique]
dans ces ateliers immenses le nombre
d'agents en charge la vérification des
éléments du train et de 80 et cette
effectif sera certainement porté à 600
lorsque la branche voici Saint-Léger
Saint-Germain sera terminé
actuellement les éléments du RER sont
vérifiés toutes les trois semaines
[Musique]
nous voici boulevard Gourdon à Paris où
se trouve le poste de commande du réseau
ferré
un décor composé de tableau de contrôle
optique de pupitre de télécommande et de
télécommunications reliées par téléphone
à haute fréquence à tous les trains en
ligne une réalisation dont nous parle
Monsieur Pierre Weill directeur général
de la RATP
vous voyez derrière moi ici le panneau
qui représente la ligne clignant cours
Orléans avec les deux voies et ici sur
les numéros du train qui se déplacent au
fur et à mesure qui fonctionne nous
avons l'outil excellent qui permet
d'intervenir dès que quelque chose se
passe et dans un réseau où on transporte
chaque jour à peu près 4 millions de
voyageurs de métro de millions et demi
de voyageurs d'autobus il ne peut pas ne
pas y avoir d'incidents dès maintenant
la moitié du réseau de métro est
entièrement surveillé à ce propos je
vous dirais que nous ouvrirons la
station Aubert sauf imprévu au début du
mois de novembre prochain donnant ainsi
une liaison en trois minutes et demi
avec la place de l'Étoile et en 8
minutes avec la défense je donne ces
chiffres volontairement pour faire rêver
les Parisiens aux possibilités nouvelles
qui seront offertes l'année prochaine un
an après nous irons à Saint-Germain et
ultérieurement et en même temps que le
tronçon central dans le courant du
sixième plan
ce qu'on appelle la branche la vallée de
la Marne car il faut insister sur ce
point la décision a été prise de la
commencer au cours des prochaines années
de façon à ce que les moyens de
transport précèdent légèrement le
développement de l'habitation nous
étudions à la fois la desserte de Rungis
et d'Orly le prolongement en banlieue
d'autres lignes du carrefour Pleyel vers
Saint-Denis et même au-delà pour plus
tard deux clichés en direction de
Gennevilliers devant en direction de
Vélizy et de Trappes les projets ne
manquent pas et le travail non plus il y
en a pour 10 15 peut-être 20 ans et
après il faudra recommencer
la station Charles de Gaulle étoile un
autre aspect de la modernisation
un univers bien loin de la
traditionnelle station de métro et son
romantique que j'ai d'eau
[Musique]
je prends mon escalier mécanique en
caméra de télévision s'il n'y a rien de
si il n'y a plus personne dessus c'est
que peut-être on ne plaisanta appuyé
dessus alors de mon pupitre je peux le
remettre en route
les voyageurs sont priés de conserver
leurs billets ils leur sera nécessaire à
la sortie
non monsieur pala introduisez votre
billet derrière vous sur le côté du
portillon
reprenez votre billet sur le dessus du
portillon poussez le portillon passé
à pas comme ça monsieur vous avez fait
tourner le portillon devant vous passez
passez monsieur passer
introduisez votre billet
reprenez-le sur le côté du portillon
pousser le portillon et passer
une recherche pour une meilleure
adaptation au service des voyageurs à
l'évolution de leurs besoins
amélioration aussi des conditions de
travail du personnel
[Musique]
c'est le type de métro qui a été choisi
pour remplacer définitivement tout le
vieux matériel
[Musique]
on ne saurait contester l'effort
impressionnant de la RATP la compétence
de ces techniciens fait d'autorité dans
le monde entier alors ou des capitales
étrangères ont confié à la RATP la
réalisation de leur métro peut-être
restons nous trône attachés aux
souvenirs du vieux bus 21 ce bus à
plateforme qui rentre pour la dernière
fois au dépôt le brun
[Musique]